l'avantagent des émissions en direct
c'est qu'on apprend les infos en direct
demande de réagir en direct
donc il semblerait je dise encore le
conditionnel mais voilà que benjamin
griveaux va démissionner du gouvernement
soit aujourd'hui soit demain benjamin
griveaux c'est le porte parole du
gouvernement
mais qui veut être candidat à la mairie
de paris et donc qui a décidé qu'ils
auraient décidé de quitter le
gouvernement je vous propose qu'on le
lait coûte ils s'étaient le compte rendu
des conseils des ministres ce matin
moi vous savez j'ai toujours été très
clair je lui ai dit je n'ai pas varié
depuis un an j'ai dit que je donnerai ma
décision au printemps printemps commencé
il ya quelques jours il se poursuit je
le crois jusqu'au 21 juin pour la fête
de la musique kitsch hall plein temps et
j'ai dit que si je devais être candidat
je démissionnerais immédiatement de mes
fonctions j'ai rien d'autre à ajouter
donc selon nos informations benjamin
griveaux partirait on attend la
confirmation évidemment par l'elysée ce
qui veut dire qu'il ya un remaniement
qui va venir puisque nathalie loiseau
elle a déjà annoncé sa démission
puisqu'elle est peut-être de liste aux
élections européennes pour europe
ecologie les verts mais alors
l'occurrence la république et comme on
avait écouté j'ai mélangé les deux mais
je pense quand les notes sont tombés le
sujet de toute façon c'est benjamin
griveaux alors au fond est ce qu il a
raison quand il vient de démissionner
aujourd'hui s'il veut noir dit dans mon
sang à l'exil à croix alors je suis je
ne suis pas il faut que je le dis très
sincèrement d'ailleurs comme mes
camarades je suis pas un spécialiste des
arcanes de la vie politique parisienne
mais ce que nous voyons tous comme
citoyen est mauvais c'est non mais
qu'est ce que nous voyons tout cela
s'est passé il ya deux il ya deux
prétendants qui émerge actuellement
comme étant les disons-le et plus
probablement consacré en dernière ligne
droite
à mon avis c'est benjamin griveaux qui
représentera la majorité présidentielle
et c'est la maire sortante anne hidalgo
n'a pas dit son dernier mot et donc
effectivement il a raison de ne pas
tarder on disait d'ailleurs que par
rapport à d'autres il s'était moins
préparés je pense qu'effectivement s'il
y va maintenant il va accroître ses
chances de dison de bétonner sa
légitimité pour être peut-être le futur
maire
paris mais à l'évidence il faut pas se
leurrer d'abord s'il y va maintenant je
pense qu'on peut estimer
enfin le connaissons un peu la macro les
rouages de la macro ni vous les
connaissez mieux que nous tous chers car
c'est absolument évident que d'une
certaine manière le président lui a dit
oui tu vas quand même raison d'y aller
il va pas y aller contre le président
est par ailleurs il a je pense comme
homme politique beaucoup plus que moi
il a une bonne estimation des rapports
de force et il l'aurait santis il
s'apprête à démissionner que c'est le
moment d'imposer en quelque sorte son
nom et son timing
face à ceux de anne hidalgo qui est loin
encore une fois d'avoir dit son dernier
mot
alexis boulanger rebondir sur ce que dit
alexis lacroix
s'il s'en va c'est qu'il a eu le feu
vert du chef de l'état so lu ment pour
démarrer sa campagne oui complètement et
ça veut dire que la campagne a déjà
commencé puisqu'on a aussi mounir ben
oui qui parlait de la ville est
également fin on a un nombre de
candidats pour cette mairie de paris qui
commence à être déjà assez ce sont eux
des candidats à la candidature sinon il
y aura une commission nationale
d'investitures agents dans les rouages d
éclairement griveaux et à la
politisation on va dire pour cette
investiture est l'idée c'est bien sûr de
commencer le plus tôt possible parce que
ça va être une campagne de longue
haleine et qu'aujourd'hui je suis
d'accord à nivelles go reste en position
de force à la mairie de paris parce que
c'est c'est pas pareil que des élections
législatives aux autres les élections
municipales
quand on tient une mairie on la tient
longtemps plus longtemps généralement on
ne sait pas à quoi ça tient de deux
modes de scrutin ou du fait que voilà on
a un rapport différent avec les
électeurs donc là ça va être une
campagne qui va devoir être un peu
créative
compte tenu en plus de la position de en
marche
et voilà de la popularité karaka dans
les sondages de benjamin griveaux
ferghana ziari benjamin griveaux ce
c'est le favori aujourd'hui vous diriez
pour l'élection lors je pense parce
qu'on se connaît il est aujourd'hui
enfin par anne hidalgo si on en croit
les sondages avaient plutôt bien parti
pour remporter cette élection à mon
grand étonnement puisque son bilan à la
baille à la mairie de paris ne me paraît
pas non plus excellent contre garde
l'état des finances de la vie
et la question de la cherté du logement
un plat problématique toujours ne sont
pas résolus maintenant l'opportunité
pour benjamin niveau de quitter le
gouvernement en ces temps de crise de
gilet jaune moi je m'interroge quand
même sur sur la réception de ce geste
dans l'électorat on a quand même une
crise institutionnelle et politique
inédite et on al'impression finalement
que ce personnage là poursuit son agenda
politique et qu'il laisse un petit peu
le bateau à d'autres en train de couler
alors que se sait pas très bien ce site
règle quand même parce qu'une occasion
fergane c'est qu'il apparaît
vraisemblable qu'il s'agit aussi d'un
agenda du président lui-même
le président lui même n'est pas sûr
n'est pas désintéressé par la mérite pas
bien sûr mais spa est ce que c'est un
bon calcul politique moi j'en doute
compte tenu effectivement de la
situation du pays
guillaume klossa et pour le coup le
président voulait qu'on parle de
d'europe il ya des élections européennes
à ces résultats c'est raté à l'aller on
avait un sujet sur l'europe aux paroles
des cales et on parle de paris et les
autres vont faire comme nous honnêtement
nous suivre moi si j'avais été dans sa
situation juridique on attend la fin des
élections européennes il ya un sujet de
décence politique c'est bien sûr mais
non mais je suis désolé je suis désolé
mais il ya un sujet aussi de décence et
d'éthique politique qu'on aime en plein
débat puisque le grand débat national
n'est pas fini on est encore en plein
débat sur les les gens n'ont jamais on
va sortir une consultation dans le cadre
de ces vitaux et de mec qui s'appelle
louis européenne à l'échelle du
continent européen où les gens veulent
de l'environnement mais ils veulent de
l'exemplarité démocratique de la part de
leurs élus et c'est extraordinairement
fort et donc l'exemplarité ça passe par
là des sens et la décence et la capacité
de se tenir et d'attendre
donc là je sais juste inquiets une
question ça c'est le problème
oui mais après après je comprends c'est
non non mais d'accord
non mais c'est l'exemplarité windhoek
jamais griveaux je pas le défendre
mais il démissionne non mais c'est vrai
que c'est bien on connaît non mais
pouvant s'accumuler en même temps il
s'est enquis santé de mai mais il ya
d'abord d'abord il
soyons très clairs dès le début il a dit
qu'il voulait parler donc on sait ce
qu'il veut et il ya une honnête est
actuel chez frankie je ne rabats jets
d'eau il ya une course en vérité qui est
lancé c'est pour ça qu'il doit y aller
parce qu'il ya quand même
cédric villani mounir jma j'oublie et
trois ou quatre autres candidats gaspard
oui mais
mais c'est enfin villani et même qu'il
avait des différentes et ils sont à deux
points donc c'est quand même assez serré
et donc moi je comprends très bien la
logique de benjamin griveaux qui est
dire je vais pas laisser les autres
faire campagne et je vais le faire et sa
logique elle est imparable et elle est
légitime
après il ya le su ça on le savait depuis
longtemps peut-être que compte tenu du
contexte on aurait dû puisque plusieurs
changements de gouvernements lumière tu
peux partir plus tôt en même temps que x
ou y parce que ils avaient ils avaient
l'opportunité de faire c'est tout ce que
je dis je dis il ya une réflexion sur le
timing avoir par ailleurs on parlait de
madame hidalgo
moi je trouve que depuis elle a fait un
très bon remaniement de son équipe parce
que depuis qu'elle s'est débarrassée
d'un certain nombre de deux de ses vins
parfois contraint l ami elle a mis une
équipe qui pour le coup est plutôt forte
et son premier adjoint que j'ai eu
l'occasion de croiser je trouve qu'il
est de bonne qualité et je pense que si
elle remonte c'est parce que elle a des
gens qui manifestement la soutiennent et
qu'elle a mis en place une équipe de
très rapprochée qui fait fonctionner
beaucoup mieux et elle a montré qu'elle
était capable de tirer des enseignements
de ces erreurs et de ses maladresses je
pense que c'est ça qui l'a fait qu'il a
fait venir et c'est sa capacité à dire
oui j'ai fait des fautes je remaniée et
j'essaie de changer un petit peu mon
comportement
maintenant à voir si ça va durer je
crois aussi que c'est une équipe aussi
qui est déjà en mode campagne
à partir du moment où elle l'a elle a
resserré c'est à dire allez les gars par
ces partis quoi elle a hélas un an
d'avancé en réalité est là elle a un an
d'avancé qu'elles sont la vérité ils
sont en bout ce qui n'était pas le cas
les précédents mais pardon de le dire
mais je vois là le niveau de discours
politiques de pensée politique et de
penser appliquée est beaucoup plus fort
sur cette nouvelle équipe resserrée que
dans la précédente
et donc là elle est beaucoup mieux
enterrer entouré par
révélateur et ça veut dire et on
reconnaît aussi chez un homme politique
sa capacité à surprendre compte de ses
erreurs et remaniée avec de la vraie
autorisé son timing aussi imposé sans
qualité donc là on voit que c'est une
vraie politique se nomme alors dernier
mot c'est vrai qu'on peut s'interroger
pourquoi cette absence étrange de
personnalités fortes qui à droite aurait
déjà en quelque sorte présenté
symboliquement le terrain est-ce que
cela marque mais c'est une publication
d'une question sans valise de ma part
est-ce que cela marque un relatif
désintérêt du parti des républicains
pour ce poste dont on sait qu'il est
quand même un très gentil pour rachida
dati qui s'est présentée et oui je sais
mais elle n'existe pas dans l'image des
gens ciblés ça se joue encore une fois
j'ai vraiment je vous la sueur
on l'a dit mais d'ailleurs ils sont
d'accord avec moi ça se joue
actuellement entre benjamin griveaux et
éventuellement mounir mahjoubi mais
surtout benjamin griveaux je pense et
anne hidalgo et bizarrement personne de
sérieux jusqu'à nouvel ordre ne songe
axe que l'hypothèse dati puisse aboutir
c'est bizarre c'est curieux qu'est ce
qui se passe pourtant la ville de paris
n'est pas une ville complètement
positionné que sur la gauche et ses
traits et ses traits c'est très bizarre
c'est une vraie question politique
un bon candidat de bernay pour les peuls
emporté apparaît de manière de manière
facile mais il faut il faut une et je
pense que cela on se focalise parce que
là on évoque bien voici 23 sondage du
jdd qui donnait anne hidalgo en tête
quel que soit le cas de figure de
candidat la république en marche et de
rachida dati mais on sait que l'élection
parisienne ça va être des élections dont
je dis cet arrondissement parce que l'un
des trois cadres vont fusionner c'est là
que ça va compliquer la donne
ça va compliquer la donne est donc là le
sujet c'est comme aussi un sujet
d'ancrage local parce qu'il ya des mères
qui font un plutôt du bon du bon travail
et donc ça ne garantit en rien que que
la république en marche aura le temps
d'être suffisamment installés localement
pour pouvoir
ça va ça ça va jouer et on peut très
bien avoir un équilibre entre ce que la
droite va rester très présente en fait
dans un tiers un bon tiers à mon avis
les enfonce voilà ça va être trois fier
et donc c'est pas du tout évident donc
le résultat va être très joué au
troisième tour très incertain
très incertain faire gaffe qui arrive ou
deering benjamin griveaux et libéral est
un candidat libéral gaselys devient le
libéralisme et et puis non pas du tout
je ne vois pas du tout s'il ya de
libérer le gouvernement de manière
générale quand même sauver vos instants
a su je serais bien embêté si vous venez
de faire la liste des mesures qui ont
profondément changé ce payer et qui
l'ont profondément sortie de deux de ces
blocages qui ont libéralisé je ne vois
pas c'est à dire que si vous voulez
m'aider à me dire je suis fou ce que je
me repose a créé on en parlera à la
jambe est ce qu'on peut pas enlever
non parce que moi je suis pas du tout je
ne fais pas de politique mais je
j'observe ce qu'on peut pas enlever à
grimaud c'est à mon avis potentiellement
sa capacité dans l'espace public
parisien a rallié derrière lui des gens
qui est sont plutôt issus de ce qu'on
entre ce qu'on appelle
traditionnellement le centre gauche et
des gens qui sont plutôt issus avant la
révolution macro nien avant 2017 civet
de ce qu'on appelle traditionnellement
le centre-droit ça je crois qu'il a
quand même cette capacité donc de ce
point de vue là il y couvre un espace
qui va en gros ferghana je me semble qui
va comme macron d'ailleurs en 2017 n'a
qui va en gros de juppé à oak au coeur
du parc du parti socialiste en gros
quand mais alors il me semble puisqu'on
est dans les étiquettes politiques
ce que je vous propose c'est qu'on passe
aux étiquettes écologie l'écologie
écologistes puisque maintenant il y en a
partout
de la cruz est simple tout le monde a
repeint sa liste en vert et tout le
monde se réclame de l'écologie d'où
notre question à quoi sert encore la
liste europe écologie les verts de
pascal canfin est devenu numéro deux de
la liste de la république en marche
alors écouter ce qu'il disait ce matin
c'était au micro de france inter
si on veut s'en être à la hauteur des
enjeux